E
MINORITY LEADER IN JUST A BIT.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY STARTS US OFF TONIGHT LIVE
FROM PHILADELPHIA.
GOOD EVENING, PETER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE PRESIDENT ARGUED THAT
WEDNESDAY MADE IT EASIER TO VOTE
EARLY OR BOY MAIL BECAUSE THERE
WAS A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.  THAT WAS
GOOD, BUT THAT WHEN REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS TRY TO LIMIT CERTAIN
PANDEMIC ERA PROVISIONS, BECAUSE
THEY SAY THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT VOTER FRAUD, THAT IS
HISTORICALLY BAD.
>> THIS IS ELECTION SUBVERSION.
IT'S THE MOST DANGEROUS THROAT
VOTING IN THE INTEGRITY OF FREE
AND FAIR ELECTIONS IN OUR
HISTORY.
>> Peter: THE PRESIDENT'S
PROBLEM IS WITH STATES HOPING TO
TIGHTEN ELECTION LAWS AND
REQUIRE VOTER I.D. INCLUDING
TEXAS.
>> THEY WANT TO MAKE IT SO HARD
AND INCONVENIENT THAT THEY HOPE
PEOPLE DON'T VOTE AT ALL.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> TEXAS REPUBLICANS CAN'T DO
ANYTHING THOUGH AS LONG AS
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ARE IN
D.C.
>> THEY GET ON TWO CHARTERED
JETS, MASKLESS, WITH AT LEAST
ONE CASE OF WHITE BEER.
>> AND ABOUT THAT FLIGHT AWAY
FROM A VOTE TO REQUIRE I.D. TO
VOTE.
>> THEY ALMOST SURELY HAD TO
SHOW IDENTIFICATION TO GET ON
THAT JET.
>> TEXAS DEMOCRATS INSIST THIS
IS NO STUNT.
>> WE ARE NOT HERE SMILING.
WE ARE NOT SPIKING THE BALL.
WE ARE NOT SAYING THAT WE ARE
HAPPY.
>> BUT THERE ARE DEFINITELY SOME
ATTEMPTS AT HUMOR LIKE THIS
LAWMAKER WHO MADE A MISSPELLED
POSTING INTENDED TO SAY MY FIRST
MEAL AS A FUGITIVE, DELICIOUS.
>> ONCE THEY HIT THE GROUND IN
TEXAS, THEY CAN BE ARRESTED AND
BROUGHT BACK TO THE CAPITOL.
AT SOME TIME THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO RETURN.
WHENEVER IT IS.
AND WHEN IT IS, WE'RE GOING TO
PASS THIS BILL OUT OF THE HOUSE.
>> SO THEY MAY JUST BE DELAYING
THE INEVITABLE.
>> WE CAN'T STAY HERE
INDEFINITELY TO RUN OUT THE
CLOCK TO STOP REPUBLICAN
ANTI-VOTER BILL.
>> VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS HOSTED
THE RUN AWAY TEXANS TODAY
TELLING RIOTERS I THINK THEY
HAVE SHOWN GREAT COURAGE AND
CONVICTION AND COMMITMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING AT
THE BIG PICTURE THOUGH,
CONDEMNING REPUBLICANS WHO CLAIM
THE LAST ELECTION WAS A FRAUD.
>> THE BIG LIE IS JUST THAT.
A BIG LIE.
>> THE TRUTH ABOUT NEW FEDERAL
VOTER PROTECTIONS THE PRESIDENT
WANTS THOUGH, HE DOESN'T HAVE
THE VOTES.
SO, UNTIL THEN, HE WILL ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO GET
MORE INVOLVED.
>> LEGISLATION IS ONE TOOL BUT
NOT THE ONLY TOOL.
>> Peter: ELECTIONS HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AND THAT'S WHY THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO MAKE SURE HIS
SIDE STAYS IN POWER.
>> JUST LIKE WE DID IN 2020 WE
HAVE TO PREPARE FOR 2022.
>> Peter: AND THE PRESIDENT CAME
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT PART OF
THE OATH HE TOOK TO THE
CONSTITUTION THAT WAS SIGNED AT
INDEPENDENCE HALL RIGHT BEHIND
US.
THE PART OF THE OATH THAT TALKS
ABOUT DEFENDING AGAINST THREATS
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
THAT IS HOW SERIOUSLY HE IS
FRAMING THE COMING FIGHT OVER
VOTING RIGHTS.